okay I've got something a little
interesting and different for you today
so you might remember that previously
maybe we can even show it on camera
three Pat we previously did this Jenga
game and the Jenga tower is sitting here
at the edge of my desk where we started
pulling pieces or I was playing pieces
of a Jenga game kind of against myself
for each two patreon contributions at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
would move a piece from the Jenga tower
and eventually the Jenga tower fell and
when the Jenga tower fell we took the
number of pieces I was able to move we
doubled it and we created a coupon code
where people got 58 percent off that
coupon code was Jenga 58 and it was a
really big success right it brought in
several dozen new patrons it got us over
the 2,100 patron mark it then brought in
several dozen new members who use the
coupon code it was it worked really
really well that game ended and I went
to the audience and I said I need
proposals I need ideas for the next game
and there were a few different ideas
that came in one idea was like putting
some kind of container or some kind of
clear plastic container on the desk and
then adding items to it until it
overflows like maybe you take a fishbowl
and you start putting tennis balls in
and eventually it will overflow but Pat
made a good point off air and others did
as well
which is that the payoff will be kind of
lame because if you start filling a
fishbowl with tennis balls when it
overflows it's not like the entire thing
falls over like the Jenga tower yeah
it'll be like one or two tennis balls
that fall out and onto the ground which
is really pretty lame Jeff had an idea
Jeff wrote in and said hey David and Pat
loved the show I think you should take a
hundred Trivial Pursuit cards and for
every correct or wrong answer you could
base the discount you and Pat could
switch off asking each other could be
fun cheers from Utah I love Trivial
Pursuit but I just don't think that it
really works for what we're trying to do
how do we how do we do Trivial Pursuit
in a visually interesting way it didn't
make sense could we couldn't make it
work okay
then we had the suggestion that Pat and
I play battleship okay we play
battleship and for each donor I play a
move and then Pat plays a move and then
depending on who wins and after how long
there's some kind
discount but the logistics are really
tough for even filming a two party game
of Battleship in a TV studio when we
have three cameras there really no way
to do it plus I do the editing I would
find out what your moves were yeah
there's really no no no way to do it and
then Carlos got in touch
Carlos wrote in and said hello David I
am Carlos I follow your show from Costa
Rica I was watching the bonus show were
you discussed with Pat about the new
patreon Jenga game and it gave me an
idea you could get an air balloon and de
manual air balloon pump the ones that
are used for kids parties for every
fixed number of patreon subscribers you
could pump the air balloon a number of
times when the balloon explodes you
generate a discount code linked to the
number of times you pump the balloon it
seems similar to the Jenga game in that
the balloon could explode at any time
this was such a brilliant idea that I
did this I actually went out and I got
one of these hand balloon pumps and I
got a whole bag of balloons and the
problem is it just doesn't work and we
were doing we were running some balloon
tests earlier big day here the david
pack there's a couple different problems
one is that let's say on day one we had
four donors and i do four pumps as i'm
doing right now
as soon as i stopped pumping the air
starts leaking out so by the next day
there's no air in it so that could be
solved because on day two we could say
okay which we had for yesterday and then
three more donors on day two then i do
one two three four five six seven but
the problem that we're coming across and
we tried this earlier is that i was
pumping this thing like a madman pat and
i got over a hundred pumps and it still
didn't pop and there's just really going
to be no way to get it to pop because
what happens is when the pressure in the
balloon gets really high it starts
leaking air out of the bottom and we
tried putting a piece of tape on it to
prevent that and the air still leaked
out so it does look the the physics of
it are just not allowing us to play the
game i mean we want the balloon to pop
it you can't just like fly off that
wouldn't be too entertaining exactly
can't have air leak but if we duct tape
it's super super securely do you think
that would work maybe I don't know it's
just I still think that it would D
inflate overnight even as I'm holding it
here the thing is just withering it's
becoming flaccid and that's that's a
real problem for a game like this so I
am we have not yet decided this is a
really good idea and we now have a whole
bag of balloons but I just I was pumping
and pumping and we got over a hundred
that's the other thing and it's just the
thing just grows and grows and
eventually air starts leaking out we
have to get a professional clown
consultant to help us out I know I think
we do need it like a professional
balloon expert or something like that
but the other thing is who knew that
these balloons could get so big this is
this is like half the size that it got
to and I'm continuing to pump it and it
just goes and goes and goes and and even
this pad I mean it's just you know you
can hear it starting to squeak so listen
I don't know what the answer is going to
be I'm up for hearing from the audience
but in the meantime please continue
contributing on patreon because when we
get to 2500 patrons we will be producing
a dozen long-form lectures from my
Boston College class this semester for
you and it's going to be really really
great I guess I'll just do the rest of
the show with the balloon next anyway
patreon.com slash david pakman show
please contribute